natural disasters climate change and
criminal networks do not respect borders
the European Union and the community of
Latin American states face these global
challenges together
the consequences of climate change
impact lives on both sides of the
Atlantic for example recent floods in
Europe and droughts in Latin America the
UN Selleck are working together in the
euroclima programme for example reduce
the vulnerability of farmers to climate
change or to map drought and
desertification in view of the important
climate conference in Paris both regions
will discuss their commitments to reduce
co2 levels the EU has recently presented
its contribution to French president
Francois Hollande Roger Staubach SIA no
of the cocktail napkin a second key
bishop or lack of the Parisian Okemah
could give me show him a little cash
more than European whoever parvenu or
subjective could develop a failure to
move out here on what they saw a body
laravel polymer style que no NOS ponemos
per their in discussion is the king Tina
castle magic in Teaneck a sermon toast
animal response I realized those 10
English comprehension Tarot show they
look at Morrissey
another key area of the EU and select
cooperation is the eradication of
extreme poverty at the UN in September
real commitments will be made on a
global level social inclusion and access
to basic needs are crucial to reduce
economic disparities here inhabitants of
a remote village in Bolivia now have
access to electricity through renewable
energy sources the euro solar program
has installed 600 kits of solar or wind
power systems in villages in eight Latin
American countries benefiting more than
300,000 people
security is another global challenge
there's renewed conflict at Europe's
eastern and southern borders having an
impact well beyond the countries
concerned the EU is involved in peace
building efforts on the Latin American
side conflicts have receded in Colombia
for example a peace agreement is being
negotiated between the government and
the FARC guerrilla but it's still
fragile a un principio de acuerdo ntral
gobierno Ellis FARC pero si dos Colombia
knows no Ven oh no CNT los beneficios
concrete Jose La Paz Nova funcionar para
nosotros la una europea es un modelo de
construcción de Paz otra vez de
proyectos concrete OHS la una Negro pea
Adam Estrada Casey funciona necesitamos
entonces ahora el desarrollo Bruegel
para integral Ariana's mess porous el
economy Adel paisa
the EU has committed to creating a trust
fund to support the peace agreement when
concluded Rural Development will be an
important part of it from small villages
to super sized cities the contrast is
striking big cities bring big challenges
and one of them is criminality
this part of Rio de Janiero used to be a
no-go zone rule by drug traffickers
today a major social policing effort is
in place a police ' avocado sushi talu
knock a la comunidad
oh mama Laura now called igb the
demolish was really staying we live in a
Cell surgery to edv you know gee how
much conflagration Shelley GOG police a
bungie huge public Allen OS from each do
police work Apaches mommy are you
considered only an ass him he nothing
was Sierra Lucas own it in on thing was
a solution in denoting qualification
pressing preggers
Ella Veera oppressor clima Josh Tbilisi
the para kept around Kumu Jabra destroys
a chippy dodging the EU in Latin America
has developed strong cooperation on anti
drug policies couple that partners on
both sides of the Atlantic are acting
together against drug traffickers
Coppola para mi representa
de pronto el mejor project okay was
implemented in materia visionary los
últimos DSO Quincy on user Lucia contra
phenomenal las drogas en el mundo
representin is passive encuentro
fundamental internal vision as distinct
as case a communica console Ocotillo yes
alumina lenguaje material Rhoda
Europe had to face a series of terrorist
attacks targeting civilians this March
in Paris was organized after Charlie
Hebdo attack which killed 20 people the
main causes a radicalization and failed
States Gilda Kurkova EU counterterrorism
coordinator sees an emerging link
between terrorist organizations and drug
trafficking we see that involvement of -
in trafficking in beings in Libya for
instance and in drugs drug trafficking
we have cocaine smuggled from Latin
America to Europe through West Africa
true thus ahead
the EU Selleck summit is taking place
before a string of important
international meetings the post-2015
development agenda in New York the cop21
climate conference in Paris and a
special UN General Assembly session on
drugs
it is a key moment to align positions
you